[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina
torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión vamos a
iniciar en ucrania donde la guerra ha
provocado la destrucción de una gran
parte del patrimonio cultural y
arquitectónico por ello un grupo de
expertos está usando tecnologías para
conservar las memorias de estos sitios
el ingeniero francés emmanuel de bauw es
especialista en recolección de datos 3d
con su escáner láser pasa por encima de
los escombros de lo que fue la estación
de bomberos del siglo 19 de jarquín
construida en
1887 era un monumento a la revolución
industrial de jarquín
[Música]
el escáner toma 500.000 puntos por
segundo solo en esta estación por
ejemplo tendremos unos 10 millones de
puntos luego recorreremos todo el
edificio y los datos serán almacenados
en un computador como las piezas de un
rompecabezas pero en 3-d
por lo que en este edificio tendremos
alrededor de 1000 millones de puntos de
medición veremos todo el inmueble y
también el interior
por lo que podremos hacer secciones para
ver una imagen del interior y el
exterior
el resultado del trabajo es una
reproducción muy precisa que se puede
girar en cualquier dirección o dividir
en secciones el propósito es evaluar el
estado del edificio y sus alrededores
para analizar lo que se ha dañado
comparando la información con los datos
previos a la guerra y así tratar de
reconstruir todas las estructuras
posibles
hay 500 edificios son solo en jarque que
serán catalogados como patrimonio
arquitectónico la mayoría está en el
área histórica del centro que ha sido
fuertemente bombardeada y destruida
todo debe registrarse en detalle con
máxima precisión para empezar a
desarrollar trabajos urgentes y
estabilizar dichos el sitio
[Música]
vamos ahora hasta eeuu porque un grupo
de estudiantes de secundaria desarrolló
un filtro de agua impreso en 3-d de bajo
costo que planea sacar al mercado con un
precio de un dólar se trata de un
proyecto que les dejó su profesora de
química durante el periodo en que las
clases tuvieron que ser virtuales a
causa de la pandemia de ccoo y 19
contaba con estos estudiantes avanzados
más
tenemos estas impresoras 3d qué tal si
hacemos algo así
no necesitamos estar en el laboratorio
para lograrlo la ciencia sencilla la
profesora expone que hay unos 10
millones de hogares en eeuu que aún
reciben agua a través de tuberías de
plomo pese a que se ha demostrado que la
exposición del cuerpo a este metal es
altamente dañina durante la niñez el
filtro funciona exponiendo el plomo
disuelto a polvo de fosfato de calcio
que hace que se solidifique este plomo y
permanezca dentro del filtro asimismo
contiene un depósito de yoduro de
potasio que hace que el agua se ponga
amarilla cuando sea hora de reemplazarlo
y realmente no es solo el plomo y el
agua la carcasa del filtro es
emocionante la química es sencilla para
remover el plomo pero la carcasa puede
ser usada para eliminar otro tipo de
toxinas y bacterias u otros materiales
así que si por ejemplo pasó un huracán o
hubo un terremoto se podría usar este
filtro también para eliminar otras cosas
del agua y hacer que su consumo sea
seguro
de eeuu pasamos a japón un país que
tiene una alta producción de desechos
comestibles sólo en 2019 produjo 5.7
millones de toneladas de desperdicios y
el gobierno tiene como meta reducir esa
cantidad en 3 millones de toneladas para
2030 pues un grupo de investigadores de
la universidad de tokio está trabajando
en un procedimiento para convertir esos
desperdicios en cemento ecoamigable
y comencé este experimento con madera
pulverizó la madera en partículas y las
usó para formar concreto sometiéndolas a
compresión por calor después de eso
pensé en usar otros materiales a base de
plantas como hojas de té tuve éxito así
que decidimos ampliar nuestra prueba a
los residuos vegetales y también resultó
ser un éxito y con high profile el
proceso consiste en secar los restos de
comida pulverizar los y comprimir los
con calor adecuar el procedimiento para
que el cemento de como amigable sea
adecuado ha tomado varios años en
principio necesitaban usar plástico para
que las partículas se unieran
adecuadamente pero luego lograron que el
cemento se compactará ajustando la
temperatura y la presión
con nuestro objetivo final es que este
cemento reemplace el plástico y los
productos de cemento que tiene impactos
ambientales mucho mayores
en el proceso de producción los
plásticos requieren petróleo crudo en
cuanto al concreto emite una gran
cantidad de dióxido de carbono en el
proceso de producción
una característica particularmente
atractiva de este material es que se
puede reutilizar independientemente
podemos seguir usando los polvos
indefinidamente y seguir circulando
nuestro objetivo es hacer que el cemento
alimentario sea reciclable
los investigadores explican que han
usado con éxito hojas de té cáscaras de
naranja y cebolla restos de café o
repollo y aseguraron que tanto los
colores como el aroma y el sabor en el
cemento son atractivos para los
consumidores japoneses
asimismo explican que este concreto se
puede impermeabilizar y se puede
proteger de ser comido por roedores y
otras plagas cubriéndolo con laca
japonesa
así finalizamos este espacio a ustedes
les agradecemos su sintonía y los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros en
france 24 de france 24 puntocom
[Música]
a